by a boy named chris that wanted to be a
police officer for a day he was seven
years old
and his mother and frank and scott two
police officers granted that wish
and when he passed away even his funeral
was a police
funeral was shooting in the air he was a
sworn in trooper
at the age of seven welcome to 20-minute
leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with loamy tech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed hello at stanford our
next guest probably has the best job in
the world
literally she gets to help kids on a
daily basis
fulfilling their wishes and making them
happy
meet denise baraharon the ceo and
co-founder of make-a-wish israel
denise is an entrepreneur who co-founded
make-a-wish israel together with her
husband
in 1996 in her brother david sparrow's
name
from make-a-wish's inception 23 years
ago over 4
000 magical wishes have been granted
denise was also the owner and president
of btc international
a buying agency in israel the
represented top firms such as macy's
calvin klein the gap and more
denise baragon welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
i'm well thank you thank you so much for
having me
i'm honored to have you here talking
about granting wishes
uh to to those that truly need it and
doing it in the most fabulous way
possible
co-founder and ceo of make-a-wish israel
a phenomenal organization worldwide but
specifically here in israel and i keep
seeing
all of the amazing work that you're
doing with some of israel's most notable
known people that are truly doing good
and i see that you know just seeing the
smiles on the on the children's faces
and everywhere that i go on on social
media and the billboards and what you're
doing now with disney
it's so inspiring and i can't wait to
dive a little bit deeper
both as to your journey and how you got
involved with your husband and
make-a-wish israel
but also a little bit more broadly
speaking and
what does it mean to make an impact in
this domain and how do you see your work
as you scale it through the years and
and what where are we
as society and where are we headed so
those are a lot of open questions we
don't have much time
but denise can you start by telling me a
little bit about how you got into
make wish israel what prompted you
because you went you came from retail
you came from different domains
yes of course so um
my beautiful brother david spiro
um at the age of 29 um was diagnosed
with esophageal cancer
and when he was diagnosed he was really
one of the most philanthropic people
um that i ever knew for thanksgiving
and even rosh hashanah often he would
leave early
and say i've got to go when he'd go to
food kitchens and give out food
way before he was even sick
and when he passed away he was here
doing his masters at hebrew university
i'm in israel
and he said i'd like you to do something
to help children
and i had no idea when that would come
about when i would
when my husband and i would um would
find the the right the right uh thing to
do
in his honor but we knew we wanted to
and we were
at a cocktail party in ranana and
somebody actually
said that they were a pirate on a wish
and i said what does that mean
and they said they were in the caribbean
and they
were asked would you put on a costume um
and be part of a child's wish and i said
wait a minute make a wish wow and that
was the epiphany that was the moment
that i said i remember make-a-wish
from los angeles where i grew up and we
asked and how can we bring make-a-wish
to israel
and that is exactly what we did and that
was 26 years ago and 4
200 wishes later um
wow it fit like a glove
because my brother david never made it
to india
he always wanted to get to india and
when he got sick
it just wasn't smart and safe for him to
to travel to india and here i would be
able
to grant wishes together with my husband
to children um that want to either be
have meet or go and each time i do that
um i really do a high five to david so
that's how that's how it happened and uh
that's the that's the the story behind
so and give me a little bit more context
you're starting this out
26 years ago this idea of granting
wishes and
first for those that don't yet know
about make-a-wish can you give me a
little bit more background about
what what does it mean a way she you you
gave a little bit of background that
it's about you know granting these
these wishes for kids that have the
passion to go
make meat or be right what does it
actually mean
tangibly to grant 4 200 wishes
um it's a high for me
for my husband for the people involved
it's a great high
and um but what does it mean it means a
lot
of corporates and a lot of individual
donors
and volunteers that are really committed
to the cause
because we don't receive funding at all
from make-a-wish international it's a
global organization it started in
phoenix arizona
um by a boy named chris that wanted to
be a police officer for a day he was
seven years old
and his mother and frank and scott two
police officers granted that wish
and when he passed away even his funeral
was a police
funeral was shooting in the air he was a
sworn in
trooper at the age of seven um
incredible
so it means getting people passionate
about the cause
and coming on and and being part of the
organization
a lot of good people right and so
what is the how does the organization
actually
function how do you you meet a kid who
has
you know unfortunately has some illness
or
or needs help in some way shape or form
and then you meet with them and you
together figure out
how you as make-a-wish could make them
feel special
or help alleviate some of the stresses
for a temporary period of time
how does it actually work right okay
well first of all
make a wish grants wishes to children
between 3 and 18
with critical illnesses so i'm talking
about
cancer liver transplant heart
transplants
diseases you've never heard of crater
willie
very very sick children that thank god
today about 60 percent
survive but 40 don't survive
it used to be different when we started
but medicine has been
better um we get a lot of referrals from
the social workers in the hospitals
we don't walk the floors of a hospital
they call us and say
um this child really needs a wish and
the wish is part of the medical
treatment
in some countries in spain doctors are
prescribing wishes
there's a prescription book really
literally in spain the doctors are
writing down you should have a wish
now um idc the um
interval in i can't say that word
um interdisciplinary interdisciplinary
um school in uh in herzeglia in israel
um the metis center dr talvan shah was a
dear friend and
he said how can i help and i said i'd
like to prove that wishes are changing
lives
that wishes are helping a sick child
what is the impact of a wish
and he said i'd be delighted to do that
so together with
um professor anachoshani they did the
first research of its kind
proving that wishes are making a huge
impact
the scholars were incredible when they
did
the control group versus the children
that got wishes
and their if somebody knows for instance
that
i don't want to continue my chemo i
can't do it anymore but they know that
messi is waiting to meet them
or if it's a small child that mickey
mouse is waiting to meet them
and you can talk about the wish then
they
they really you see um the difference
in their physical mental and emotional
um emotional state of their of their
critical illness it truly is part we say
the the doctors give the medicine and
make a wish gives the magic
and the magic is just as important to to
these children
i i love that so 26 years later and
make-a-wish israel is a
very well-known organization some of the
most well-known people
and inspiring people across israel's
domains are
are partnering with you and working now
with disney and i see the necklace that
i can't wait to go to folks and
and and get for myself how do you grow
how do you grow an organization over 26
years that
is you know donor based it is
100 impact doing good
how do you make it a brand and one that
people
trust and people connect with so deeply
and emotionally
great great question um we are super
we're a super brand in the world we're
the most loved
uh children's charitable foundation in
the globe
uh we are in 45 countries so
we are completely transparent from every
dollar spent 86 cents goes to wishes
and we can show that in our um you know
me dote is um an organization that
shows efficiency and we can show that 86
cents goes to so we have the
adult certificate in a make-a-wish
international
is now a charity navigator we have four
stars which is the highest rating
and what i do is i take my business
background
as the president of btc international in
the textile industry
i went to school at fit and learned how
to be an
uh offshore agent um and i represented
macy's and
dmx marshall's calvin klein many i take
that
and i say in order to
have a successful foundation you have to
run it like a business
and that is what my husband and i do
with an incredible uh
group of people so for instance i'll
give you the disney um
the disney situation i went to the ceo
of disney israel
and i said i would like very much to
develop a
product um for the largest
chain of stores in israel which is the
fox group meaning
mango american eagle fox home ra
foot locker huge huge uh conglomerate
627 stores
and i said can we develop a necklace can
we use mickey mouse which i'm wearing
can we use the face uh and the back of
the
necklace has make-a-wish on the on the
back on the closure
can we take this partner with fox
and develop here's the silver and here's
the goal and develop a product
for um purely for the granting of wishes
and so i designed the box because of
again my background
and disney is the number one
partner of make-a-wish globally but
they've never done co-branding
so this now we're going to show to the
world to make a wish international
and hopefully the world will take this
on so disney
contributes great people we've never
done a product that's co-branded
so that's very very exciting and the
noaa cleared and then
benedict and and all of those incredible
um talents they in susha leo souchow
they have become international
ambassadors because they themselves
are the largest brands in israel and
they want to connect themselves
with make-a-wish so when i asked them
they were delighted
delighted and as de vera chairman of the
board says all the time
i i can't use my celebrity celebrity
hood
just to get a discount at night um i
need to
to do for others with my face he said my
face is my
you know is is so valuable to you know
today because of the amount of
tv and theater that he does but i should
use it
in a good cause and he's incredible he's
really really incredible in that
and all these others i love that
i i think it's it's so innovative taking
this approach and i think that one of
the things that i
that i love most about this initiative
uh whether intended or not it's it's
this idea that
anybody can become a contributor at you
know
various moments you know even when it's
it's not intentionally going now to the
make-a-wish website and
and making a donation which which has a
lot of friction it does
regardless of how we look at it there's
a lot of friction for the average person
to make a donation even if it's a one
dollar donation
and but at when you when we're when you
know we're doing something for ourselves
like
going shopping for for textiles or
clothes and these stores and we see this
and we see this mickey mouse and you
know we're creating this brand where
you know by by wearing this necklace i'm
saying i too care and i too
am a part of grant want to be a part of
granting wishes i think it's
completely innovative and i love it and
i can't wait to see
everybody in israel including myself
walk around with it with a mickey mouse
necklace and then the
and the design of the box is beautiful
denise what are some of the biggest
challenges that you've had over the past
26 years i'm always curious about you
know you're saying you're running this
like a business
which makes a lot of sense to me because
that's how you scale that's how you make
it a greater impact 4 200 wishes
that's incredible what are the biggest
challenges you faced
along the path um i faced
the fact that there are i don't know if
you know this but there's 46 000
foundations in israel 46 000
46 000 foundations there are only seven
that have the middle
the efficiency uh a stamp
but there are 46 000 so many for the
army
so many for sick children not like make
a wish because it's one
wish one child i'll explain that in
depth in a moment because there's a lot
of
uh children's foundations that take
people together on a group but i'll tell
you that the reason why make-a-wish is
so special
um but you know from the army to
holocaust
many many foundations and there are
your number of global
uh global uh international
supporters uh that some of them are
israeli that live abroad or what have
you but there's your
number you're not there's not a handful
there's maybe two handfuls of the very
wealthy that contribute
so it's difficult and if you're not
getting help from the government
it's it's a real it's a real struggle
and we do not get help from the
government so it's going to those same
people so what i created
again um because i had to think out out
of the box i created something called
the shared appeal
and i started that in australia i said
to the ceo
what if we go to the jewish community in
australia
and we do fundraisers and split the
prophets 50-50
because so many jews abroad want to give
to israel
so he said let's do it and
the tagline of that is give to where you
live and where you love
and i've been in australia three times
um i went with david garcia
the artist of this actually you've seen
his work the butterflies in the airport
and the bike riders
he made this sculpture but he came with
an exhibit of all of
his art to australia and beer came and
did his stand-up
um and we split the prophets and then we
did it in florida
and we did it in london and that is
my way of coming out of
israel proper and doing fundraising so
that was another innovative thing and
we're hoping very soon to do it together
with the the emirates uh hani is a dear
friend of mine
we meet all of the make-a-wish people
once a year abroad
uh somewhere in the world and so i'm
close to honey
and i said let's do something in in uh
an emirates
so we're hoping to do it in november
around
uh the formula one because roy nissani
the very first uh formula one driver is
on our board of directors
and i have to say it's very exciting for
all of the
uh all of your viewers that if you go
into roy nissani
you will see that he had
the make-a-wish logo put on the back of
the formula one car
so wow it's incredible it's incredible
that he was able to achieve that
so it's very exciting i i have to say i
think all the time about you know
impact and impact at scale and you know
when i'm hearing 4 200 wishes in 26
years and running into like a business
you know i'm
i think there's so many lessons to be
learned from you know the way that you
grew and are still growing make-a-wish
israel all the way from the you know
this idea of bringing it
to israel for personal for for the
personal experience but also now
to actually going into the retail and
partnering with disney and and
unfortunately 20 minutes doesn't even
begin to articulate
how you know the fascinating journey but
but my goal through this show is to you
know just get a little bit of
taste so that i can now explore much
more deeply and hopefully
incite curiosity with a lot of other
people but denise are you ready for a
few
uh fun questions sure
like fun all right we'll start we'll
start off easy
favorite subject in school k to 12.
uh k to 12. i think my great one of my
greatest memories is
art um when i put on a smock today when
i cook
i remember the easel and finger painting
and if i could be a child again one of
my
my colleagues in brazil they say they're
so
so lovely the founders of make-a-wish
brazil they say
the way the reason we look so good
without plastic surgery is because we
were playful we decided at our age to
become playful
and i have visions of that all the time
i'd like to say math or something but no
it was literally finger painting
probably in first grade
that's my greatest memory i love it i
love it
who is one of your role models real or
fake one of your role models in life
um i think that a role model uh
definitely is oprah
the giving you know her giving was
remarkable
um globes uh just did a whole article
about one of my role models and it was
my brother
and it was the entire piece was about my
brother and his giving
that that um it was the spark
that uh this his spark of getting i love
it
certainly my spark so he's he was
certainly a roman and oprah certainly
is as a woman i love it and
the hardest question of them all not the
most important but still the hardest
three words that you would choose to
describe yourself or if i were to ask
avi
or anybody that is involved with
make-a-wish how would they describe
denise baragon
well i i made a sculpture
it's in ranana i sculpt that's my
passion
and it said on the bottom my beloved
brother who loved to love
and it's three sides of a woman
um but actually there's four and people
have said that one is philanthropy one
is family and motherhood
and one is giving um
one is philanthropy one is excuse me one
is philanthropy
one is business and profession and
one is family and everyone that knows me
said i cannot believe that you didn't
have four
because the fourth is passion so i
am extremely passionate in everything
that i do
so i think there's four sides and three
but actually i made that sculpture
for the city of granada that that's
beautiful and for this episode we'll
take four words and not three i think
it's much more fitting denise thank you
very very much for coming on this was
inspiring i've been following
make-a-wish for a long long time
and and thank you for the inspiration it
was just fantastic
my pleasure and i've been following you
and your great success so thank you mike
thank you take care bye denise bye